في فرنسا محطه جديده في معركه ليد ذراع
بين الحكومه الفرنسيه والنقابات حيث توقفت
امدادات المشتقات النفطيه في عموم البلاد
صباح اليوم وفق ما اعلنت قناه الفرنسيه في
وقت اغلق غضبون محطه الشوز النوويه في
منطقه اردان شرق فرنسا وانطلق التحركات
شعبيه ونقابيه واسعه النطاق احتجاجا على
مشروع قانون التعديل نظام التقاعد والذي
من ضمنه رفع سن التقاعد الى 64 عاما بدلا
من 62 عاما هذا ويعد التحرك الشعبي
المرتقب اليوم امتدادا لتحركات سابقه اخرى
حدثت خلال الشهرين الماضيين وياتي تحت
شعار اغلاق فرنسا كما سيشمل قطاعات
الاستراتيجيه معينه فضلا عن انه سيمهد
الطريق امام بدايه اضراب مفتوح يمتد لايام
عده كما يتوقع ان يشارك اكثر من المليون
شخص
مشاهدينا من باريس ينضم الينا مباراه
العربي حسين قنابل الامريكي حسين نتحدث
اذا عن احتياجات هي الاعلى ربما منذ
التاسع عشر من يناير الماضي دعنا نبدا
بابرز ملامح خريطه التظاهرات والاحتجاجات
والتحركات اليوم حسين
نعم احمد ستكون التظاهرات غير مسبوقه من
حيث حجمها ربما منذ العام 95 عندما تظاهر
ملايين الفرنسيين ضد اصلاح سابق لنظام
التقاعد في عهد جاك شيراك في بدايه ولايته
الاولى عندما كان الانجيو يتراس الحكومه
حدثت تلك التظاهرات في نوفمبر وديسمبر من
عام 95 تظاهرات اليوم ستكون شبيهه لها
خصوصا اذا قررت النقابات الرئيسيه هذه
الليله ان يصبح الاضراب مفتوحا لعده ايام
وربما لعده اسابيع خارطه التظاهرات
والتحركات اولا ستكون هناك حواله 260
تظاهرات تتوزع على مدن باريس
ومارسيليا
تولوز نيس اكان
وعده مدن ايضا اخرى لا نستطيع بلادها
جميعا
هذه التحركات على مستوى باريس ستبدا عند
الثانيه من بعض الظهر بالتوقيت المحلي
ستنطلق من امام محطه مترو الانفاق سيرفر
بابيلون وصولا الى بلاستيتالي ساحه
ايطاليا وتقول مذكره للاستخبارات الداخليه
هنا انه من المتوقع ان يشارك في تظاهرات
اليوم ما بين مليون ومئه الف ومليون واربع
مئه الف كما يتوقع وجود بضع مئات من
المتشددين جدا من انصار السترات الصفر
هؤلاء قد يحاولون القيام باعمال تخريب
نتحدث طبعا عن المجموعات المتشدده العنيفه
ضمن سترات الصفر وليس عن كل تحرك السترات
الصفر احمد ما الذي تراهن عليه الاطراف
الداعيه للاضراب تحديدا وهل من مؤشرات على
ان بامكانها دفع الحكومه نحو التراجع
نعم هناك يعني محاولات لدفع الحكومه نحو
التراجع النقابات تقول انه طالما كان
ممكنا دفع الحكومه الى التراجع في عهود
سابقه خصوصا في اشاره الى تظاهرات العامه
95 التي اشرت اليها فلماذا لا يحاولون هذه
المره ايضا الحكومه تقول ان ارتفاع متوسط
الاعمار في فرنسا ينهك ميزانيه نظام
التقاعد وبالتالي فان العجز في ميزانيه
نظام التقاعد سيصل الى 20 مليار يورو
بحلول العام 2030 وانه لا يمكن مواجهه هذا
العجز الا برفع سن التقاعد من 62 عاما حتى
اربعه وستين عاما وهذا ما يرفضه
المتظاهرون والمضربون الاضراب والتظاهرات
سيشمل الاضراب تحديدا قطاعات النقل
والطاقه والصحه والتعليم وعمال المصافي
النفطيه وعمال جمع النفايات وعمال قطاع
الصناعات الكيماويه وعددا كبيرا ايضا من
القطاعات مع اشاره اخيره الى ان النقابات
الرئيسيه الثماني هي التي دعت الى تحرك
اليوم وعلى راسها ثلاث نقابات
الكونفدراليه العامه للعمل واف او فورس
اوفرير القوه
العاملهدراليه الفرنسيه للعمل